in the lobby of Ramsey solutions cable
Caleb and Molly dropped by hey guys how
are you good
been better oh what's going on how can I
help
we are $700,000 in debt what we are
farmers from Montana and we disagree
about how to handle it I am ready to
declare bankruptcy as awful as that
would be he has kind of dragged us
through several failed businesses and
working it out and making payments just
sounds kind of like another scheme to me
at this point and I'm hesitant to get to
dive into that and I'm exhausted and
we're kind of hopeless and don't really
know what to do break that down for me
how much is out on the farm
well we lease a farm but we go about
four hundred and fifty thousand dollars
on equipment mm you know inputs and such
okay and what is the other 300 thousand
yeah that would be like well I owe my
dad for some stuff and then now how much
do your dad
fifty thousand and then I uh you know
for some equipment repairs and some
chemical bills from last year Venga
bills yep okay and how much is that oh
it probably comes up to hundred that's
six hundred yeah then there's another
roughly hundred thousand dollar lawsuit
that we're in over equipment repair that
we rented I don't know four or five
years ago now what is that lawsuit about
some repairs that were done to a machine
that we rented and I disagreed with all
of them and you rented it and they said
you broke the machines so they did the
repairs and surgery for them yep okay
and so in a sense other than the 50k
there with your dad this is all business
debt
in a sense I mean you've signed
personally for it but it's all business
debt and you leased the farm okay you're
still operating the farm yep okay and so
she wants to file bankruptcy what's your
plan sell a bunch of equipment and get
out of the debt I mean get out as much
for the debt as possible and work out
settlements with everybody how would you
work it out I mean how you gonna make
money well I have a truck I do some
trucking one time but the bank won't
guarantee that we can keep the truck or
any vehicles you won't in bankruptcy
either right right okay and so you quit
farming and drive the truck to pay off
the bills and sell off the equipment is
your plan mhm is that what you're saying
Calum Evie okay all right okay and but a
part of the equipment is the truck and
what is the truck worth probably only
$30,000 those 18-wheeler tractor yeah
okay all right is it reliable yeah into
shape mm-hmm okay what can you make
driving truck oh so variable but
anywhere from 80 to 150 thousand here
okay I'll get kids yep three you talking
about being over the road with that
truck yeah I'm usually gone two weeks at
a time and only home for a day he wants
so long but that's only an offseason
when you're not farming right right
right you know and what we're talking
about here is you're doing that
full-time right you'll be going all the
time yep okay let's pretend you file
bankruptcy and you walked away from
everything toss up by the keys clean
start fresh done what are you gonna do
for living then go get a job at a farm
or something like that I suppose mmm how
old are you 30
what were the other failed businesses we
did custom harvesting primarily custom
harvesting yeah we own the combines and
Amish and go to Texas and back and cut
for farmers and that didn't work nothing
and the other business that's about it I
guess one other business has no suckers
so Molly you were exaggerating when you
said certain businesses
it feels like several there's been well
in the farming and we were in business
with his family too for a while and did
that go bad yes it's a it's a
partnership that sunk okay that was a
different business mhm okay well it's
the same stuff just okay in partnership
so Caleb what I am hearing is that you
have attempted to do the farming
business the way a lot of people have
attempted to with large piles of debt
three different times in three different
ways
mm-hmm have you figured out this any
working yeah okay is if you go back in
dad I in the farming business again I'm
gonna find you and kick your butt
because it for three times you got to
figure out this ain't working really I
mean the combine thing the reason it
went downs you had big freaking combine
payments
the reason the partnership on the
business failed is you had big equipment
payments and now you got it again mm-hm
because you've got in your head the way
you grew up that this is the only way to
do farming and it's not the only way to
do farming because it's not working and
your problem is you're not an unusual
story I deal with farmers all the time
that are dealing with what you're
dealing with it's very difficult farming
is to start with very hard work
unbelievable hard work but on top of
that it's very difficult to do it with
these big freakin equipment payments
it's almost impossible to make it and
and yet farmers still you know Doug
Ramsey doesn't understand farming no I
understand business I understand
business and math and farming is a
business and math does not get an
exception because you are feeding
America and we appreciate you feeding
America but it doesn't you know
patriotic stuff aside the freaking math
has to work and that's the problem here
huh what will the equipment bring oh I
would say roughly 450,000 you think
it'll bring enough to pay it all off
well not quite no we'd be about a
hundred thousand short okay so more like
three thing right yeah okay all right
and so basically that's going to leave
you about three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars if you sold off the
equipment
that you have to settle and clear making
a hundred driving truck and feeding
three kids okay so I'm guessing you can
probably settle most of that not
counting your dad for about probably
1020 cents on the dollar
it's gonna take some negotiation but I
mean you probably settle a hundred
thousand dollar vendor bills for twenty
five thousand bucks with my gas okay and
so if you do that at say twenty five
cents on the dollar and you sell off the
equipment you know we basically got it's
gonna take you about a hundred hundred
hundred and some change to get out of
debt can you do that making a hundred
and twenty yeah but you're not gonna see
your family for two years that's what
you're giving up or you got to find
another career that's different than
driving a truck that's gonna make you
some more money okay
I don't care which one you do this just
doesn't sound very fun sounds like a
very tough thing to go through
so are you guys in a good church yep
good okay make sure you're sitting down
your pastor and talking about your
marriage as soon as you get home and
start doing that once every two weeks
have a checked out okay because this
stuff Sharon and I were right where
y'all were it'll destroy your life and
let's draw your marriage it's not worth
it's just stuff okay I could go either
way if I'm you but you both got to be up
for whichever way it is Molly I think
you're just I think you're tired and
your tank is empty and you ain't got
much fight left in you and you've lost
confidence in his ability to do math and
then that some of that's valid all of
that's valid actually but if I were in
your all shoes the way I look at
bankruptcy I look at it like a divorce I
try everything first to not do that and
so let's try some stuff but it has to
have a plan and Caleb for her to go
along with that she's gonna have to see
a detailed plan and she's gonna have to
have like you're gonna have to have a
new tattoo right inside your arm that
says I don't freakin borrow money for
anything ever again the rest of
life no matter what my stupid family
says that tattoo right there on the
inside of your arm you got it because
you can't ever because she's done man
she's gonna give you you know she's
gonna stick with you but she's done with
this process of going deeply in debt is
that fair Caleb sure is you know so
she'll run with you on this you to put
some gas back in her tank if she can see
that we're gonna give this a hard run
and she'll she'll handle the kids while
you're on the road a little bit if we
got a hard run and you sell off this
stuff but only if you never go back
that was Sharon's of me we said never
again never again then we stayed married
we've I killed each other but we stayed
married thanks for dropping by guys
thank you thanks